Is there a supplement that could possibly see in the blood?
Yeah, there are supplements that can thin the blood.
That you do have to be careful on it for out of blood thinner than you do have to be careful with supplements that could thin the blood too much of you enough with bruising and stuff like that.
Your number one blood city supplement is garlic by far.
So years ago, I've had a lot of heart patients, I actually have on the blogs multiple blog posts about cardiovascular health that effect we're going to course in cardiovascular health probably will be done until after the first of the year.
But garlic is your number one blood city nutrient.
There are some plugged in benefits with fish oils.
But again, just like with anything else, you don't just want to treat the symptom you want to treat the cause cardiovascular, especially there's a lot of under lighting caused cardiovascular disorders.
Most of the time it has to do with either a toxin or a biotoxin that gets under the layer of the epithelial layer of the blood vessels is called endothelial cells.
You can have a toxin or a biotoxin get under the endothelial cell and affect the different receptors in the smooth muscles.
We have these smooth muscles that wrap around the vessels that function to increase or decrease blood pressure.
I wouldn't want to increase blood pressure. You have to increase blood pressure or you even stand from a sitting position, your blood pressure has to go up about 10 to 20 points or you will pass out.
They have to be able to shut blood to your brain instantaneously.
It's a hormonal reaction that's to be partly with the neurological sympathetic system as well, but mainly hormonal.
And so there's a lot of different things that can block the different receptors you've heard of like ACE 2 drugs, those are blocking ACE 2 receptors.
We have a lot of great tea extractions, one of the most potent beneficial ACE 2 receptor antagonists that can be really beneficial for a person.
So as for spheratrial, there's just a plethora of different things.
I do write about a lot of that on the blog posts that I have on cardiovascular.